these elections are the first
opportunity for people to give their
view on the main parties since the
brexit deadline was missed but only if
they live in England and Northern
Ireland now in England more than 29
million people from every region except
London will have a chance to vote for
almost eight and a half thousand
counselors in 248 councils 151 are
electing every seat in the chamber and
the rest a third now most of these were
last contested in 2015 on the same day
as David Cameron surprise general
election victory and the Conservatives
did very well indeed so they're
defending nearly 5000 seats more than
double than that of labour on around
2000 while you Kip could lose almost all
of its remaining seats in local
government they're defending 176 seats
in places like fanuc in Kent but of
course brexit could be a factor in many
of these results with labour and the
Conservatives competing for control in
areas like Dudley and northeast
Lincolnshire and the amber Valley while
the remain of votes could potentially
help the Lib Dems take control in
Winchester now in the metropolitan areas
labour is aiming to take control of both
call the Dale and Trafford councils and
if they did that would be the first time
that they controlled both for 15 years
there are also mayoral elections in
Bedford in Leicester Middlesbrough
Copeland and Mansfield and a contest for
the first north of time city region mare
these elections will also be a key test
for the DUP leader Arlene Foster has
parties defending 130 of the 462 seats
being elected in Northern Ireland 11
districts votes there will have to wait
though until Friday and they take a
little longer to count because they use
a proportional system unlike the rest of
the UK